Shika no ko no ko no ko ko shi tan tan.
Shika no ko no ko no ko no ko shi tan tan.
No!
No.
Shika
no ko no ko ko shi tan tan.
She's freaking out.
I'm always freaking out.
Oh my god!
Don't add me to your friends list!
That was a notification of people trying to add me to a friends list!
Get out of here!
My voice is really bad today.
Oh my goodness.
Hello everyone!
Get out of here!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
She's down with the sickness.
Actually, no!
I'm... oh my god.
Of course if I say something...
You guys will all be freaking about it.
But no!
Well, I was gonna say I'm all better.
But I'm not all better.
I still have a cough.
Jason will have a membership.
The Japanese... with what?
Brain rot is real.
Shika no ko no ko no ko shi tan tan.
Minto minto...
Minto minto minto minto...
Minto phantom.
Doesn't really roll off the tongue very well though.
Welcome to Tatrio!
It's been a long time since I've...
Since I've played this before.
It's been a really, really, really...
Really, really, really, really long time.
Still don't understand the deer meme?
What is there to understand?
It's just a catchy song, that's all.
Hello.
Minto minto minto minto...
Minto phantom.
Thank you.
We wisps take after you.
We have no choice but to be freaky.
And clowny, apparently.
Yeah, it's just an earworm.
From an anime.
What round did you get to?
Ambulance?
I think it was 165?
I...
I think so.
Mint is good at Tatrio?
Of
course I am.
Of course I am!
She's a world champion.
Of the digital world.
I'm the digital world champion.
I'm the one who sent you digital monsters to save the digital world.
But yeah...
Move aside firestorm.
Mint's in town now.
I don't even know who that is.
I think.
That's how insignificant they are to me.
I just figured it's a Friday...
It's a Friday...
night.
And I haven't played this in literally years.
With you guys.
Sorry, Minto lovers.
You just made that account now.
Minto lover.
The one hour deer song is giving me a migraine.
What the?
You can message me even?
Get out of here!
I don't think you should listen to it for an actual migraine.
Maybe.
You know?
I think...
It's not meant for that.
How are you guys doing this?
You're not my friends!
Hi!
There's a streamer mode?
Okay, I'm gonna streamer mode.
Hold on, let me hide my screen.
Hold on.
Where is it?
I just have to find it.
Um...
I'm gonna turn off notifications real quick.
Also.
Let's see.
Oh, I cannot turn them off.
Really?
Oh wait, here we go.
Notify me.
Off.
Is there a streamer mode?
No cussing in my chat.
Can you be my dear friend?
Oh, what's that?
Someone gave me one month of Tetrio supporter!
Stop it!
Freaking
cussing!
You freaking freaks!
Any time that I would get mad at Mataro while we were together...
Any time I would get mad at her...
She would be like, you freaking freaks!
That's what you sound like.
You freaking freaks!
That's what you sound like right now, Mint.
She would do that every time.
When will you learn?
Attractions have consequences!
I don't think there is a streamer.
Unless I'm blind.
Which is...
I mean, it might be these glasses, to be honest.
It's my favorite YouTube video.
It's a classic, truly.
I've been wanting to catch a Mint stream.
Glad to have made it.
Welcome!
What's with the shades?
I just thought they were cool.
You're blocking the messages now.
So maybe it's okay.
Maybe now.
Yeah, maybe.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm cool.
I'm cool now.
But I'm still getting notifications when somebody has me.
Two months, baby!
Yippee!
Wait, under account you can edit your privacy settings.
Oh, I can?
Okay, thank you.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I didn't know it'd be like this!
Wait.
Under accounts, a privacy set...
Where?
Wait.
Oh!
Change account settings.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on.
Write a little something about me.
Who can add me as a friend?
My friends can only add me as a friend.
Nobody.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
I think I have to do this.
I think I have to do everybody can see what room I'm in so that we can all play together.
Who can send me direct messages?
Nobody!
Okay.
There we go.
Quit talking to me!
What the?
Still adding me, though.
Wait.
Streamer mode is...
It's under configuration desktop.
Desktop?
I don't see it.
Hmm.
Desktop.
Oh, it's for desktop version, not browser.
Oh, okay.
Okay, anyway.
It should be fine now, I think.
Okay.
Let's...
I'm gonna do a little bit of a warm-up.
Okay?
I'm gonna do a bit of a warm-up.
Don't be shocked by my Zen level, okay?
Or anything like that.
I also made this account today.
I made this account today.
So...
Do 40 lines?
No, we're gonna...
Uh...
Yeah, I had to make a smurf account.
Mint deleted her old account.
I did!
I actually tried to log in back into it, and it was like, this account is deleted.
So I had to make a whole new one, baby.
Which I was really happy this wasn't taking my name.
Yeah.
So, you know.
I deleted my old account.
I nuked it.
Yeah, I was...
It's gone.
I scrubbed it from the internet.
So nobody could ever, ever see.
A fresh start.
Anyway.
Chat summary is wild.
What is Mint Zen mode?
Why...
Does it like...
Does it...
Does it take what I say or only what the chat says?
Weird.
Anyway.
If you're gonna come in here and be a big old jerk to me...
You can go be a jerk in someone else's chat.
That's all I'm gonna say.
Look at that!
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
And then...
Nope.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
It's space.
Wow.
Look at this.
It's this base rift.
It's kind of...
And then shift.
You guys can't be adding me while I'm practicing.
Okay?
You guys...
Chill out.
Okay?
I was...
I took the screenshot earlier of my...
Of my...
Thumbnail.
Do you guys like my thumbnail?
Do you guys like that?
Pretty nifty, eh?
Yeah.
Tetris is fun.
Tetris is a bit stressful for me.
But I do enjoy it.
I mostly enjoy just being able to play games with you guys.
So, even if I'm bad at something, I just choose it because I'm like, well, I at least have something to play with people.
So...
To me, it doesn't really matter if I'm good or bad.
I'm just kind of...
I'm just...
I'm just vibing.
And we can all vibe together on this lovely Friday.
You know?
I didn't trust myself to keep building that.
Wow!
Murphy!
My day is pay.
And my Oshii is cute.
You know it.
Thank you for that.
Why'd you send that?
See my happy birthday!
Sing me...
Hold on.
Here.
I'm just...
I'm practicing real quick.
Give me a second.
Give me like one minute.
Okay.
Square block.
Oh.
There we go.
Good.
This is pretty clean though.
Isn't it?
Didn't you say?
Clean.
I remember one advice someone gave me a long time ago in the past.
They were like, this one, these Z blocks, don't put them vertical if you can help it.
Is that still a true statement?
Yes.
Or no.
Disgust.
Like that.
Don't put it like that.
Build flat.
No.
I think the meta changed.
That's the...
That's all I know.
Now what?
Don't destroy chat.
You know, I'm...
This is a glorified Zatudan stream.
So...
Okay.
I think I've practiced enough.
Let's see.
Where'd you go?
D.O.I.
Boss, you think of us as people.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to say that.
I didn't mean to let that slip.
Could you please favor me with the terrifying lows, the dizzying highs, and the creamy middles of one of your famous birthday greetings?
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear D.O.I.
D.O.I.
D .O.I.
D .O .I.
D.O.I.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy
birthday, dear D.O.I.
D.O.I.
My voice is cracking a lot today.
I
don't remember how to do this...
Multiplayer.
I think I create a room, right?
Play by my rules.
So, if I create a public room...
Oh, made mince room.
Oh!
Pa-sam!
Oh, I did it.
Super Lobby!
I think I've only ever had that once before.
What is this lobby?
Uh oh, I think there's people gonna come in that don't know who I am.
Uh oh.
And it keeps going!
I can hear it very faintly.
If you win, you get a permanent badge to show you wanted a room with 100 plus people.
Try to win.
I want that!
This is a good thing no context mint is the best.
Look up maid mint on YouTube channel!
200 people.
It keeps going.
Hello maid mint, why are they calling me out?
You are so pro VTuber.
Wait, I'm scared.
Who are these people?
If you are unsure how we have 100 players, it's a lobby.
How to survive it.
Wait, why are there people in here being like...
There's people in here being like, this is why there's so many people playing.
I don't know, is there a limit in this room?
Is there a limit?
We're just gonna let everybody in who wants to join.
Hey, don't quit.
I saw I went down to 240.
800.
Oh yeah!
The real limit is the servers going down.
I hope people don't come in expecting... they're gonna see me wearing my freak phantom glasses.
Honestly, probably the best...
The best introduction.
Look, I'm level 2!
I'm level 2!
There's people literally level like 3000 here.
Oh gosh.
We even have Yukari Yakumo of Touhou fame.
The freak phantom glasses are the perfect introduction.
I think so too.
You need to be level 3 before you can chat.
Really?
Test.
You're right!
I can't even chat in my own room.
Stop laughing in both chats.
This is so cursed.
Free her mods!
Give me special privileges!
I think we're done though.
What is plus 3?
Does that mean spectators?
I can't chat because I'm not level enough.
That's right.
Even though it's your own chat.
Even though you made your own room.
Okay.
Well, I guess we'll start.
Got it.
Oh, player limit.
Auto start.
Public room.
No, you can't be anonymous and join.
You have to be a...
You have to be someone...
You have to be willing to share your stuff.
We're not hiding likes here.
And for the record, I always kept my likes up open.
I always liked what I wanted to.
Despite if people could see it or not.
Wait for 300?
Okay.
We'll wait for 300.
Oh, they're crying.
Even butt wiping?
I don't think I ever liked anything about that.
Did anybody ever even look though?
I never even thought about it.
I never thought that people would look at my likes.
So maybe that's why I just didn't care.
We did look?
Really?
Let...
Let anons in any way.
There's no real danger.
No, I just wanna...
It's not that it's a danger thing.
I just wanna see people's names.
I wanna know what to call them.
Okie dokie.
Save.
And let's start at 307 players, baby.
I'm scared.
Minto the hero would have kept the likes tab.
Wait, how do I do this again?
Ok.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot how much I...
No, not caps lock this.
I forgot how much I like the music in this game.
Shoot.
Oh gosh, you guys.
I'm nervous.
I'm so scared right now.
I'm really nervous right now.
Oh my god.
Wow.
It's all like...
It's all coming in.
It's all coming in too fast.
Hold on.
Don't, don't, don't shoot anything at Minto, please.
I haven't played this game in like so many years, ok?
My granny brain's gotta keep up.
My granny...
Oh shoot.
Why did I do that even?
Screw it.
Oh.
This one.
Boop.
Guys, am I gonna make it?
Oh.
Be honest.
Are we gonna make it, chat?
Chat, are we gonna make it?
Something something chat, is this real?
I don't remember how to teaspoon.
I learned maybe, like, once.
I learned once, and then... never again did I remember.
Yescent.
Okay.
What rank do you think we'll get?
Oh.
What's that sound?
Sounds like little ants running around.
What is that sound?
Is it my headphones?
Oh my god, I escaped.
Oh, no I did not.
I think we're done, though.
Maybe a little bit.
Oh shoot.
100 players left!
I'm doing it!
Dressed up!
What did I get?
I don't want to see this.
A virtual ghost!
Oh my god, it's a bloodbath out here.
Can't believe I ranked lower than Min.
Really?
You can't believe that?
Who else is in here?
Who's this?
Patience!
Oh, we can... wait.
How do I see what my rank was?
That's what I'm trying to look for, sorry.
Mint is too pro.
I know.
This person's even... their name is Kill.
They come in with hostile intentions.
They come in with too hostile of intentions.
Get his ass!
Why piss by?
Fast Bulba living up to their name.
The games, you would think with 300 people, they would go by like really slowly.
But no.
Cheater!
You're cheating!
Oh my god, he's gonna get his ass wiped?
Get wiped.
Oh my gosh, we're already down to two.
Before I can even finish my sentence, great point!
Oh my god, wait.
No way!
I feel like I recognize this name.
I feel like it.
Who else would get 69?
Nice!
With these freaky glasses on.
Wait, who got next to me?
Hello.
Don't sniff up.
Get out of here.
Sniff up.
Okay, bye!
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I got the funny number.
That's so silly.
GG Grape.
I don't want to eat grapes anymore.
What are you talking about?
I love grapes!
What is this?
One, one, one.
Oh!
One.
One out of one.
Oh.
They won.
Bye grape!
See ya.
Alright, let's try again.
Ready?
Tang, tang, tang.
Three hundred and twenty eight!
Holy cow!
Guys, this is a chill game, okay?
This is...
This is a chill game.
We're just chilling.
We're vibing, okay?
Just take it easy, everybody.
Take it easy.
Take it...
Oh!
Wait, I forgot.
I thought I had something different.
That's fine.
Oh!
There we go.
Just...
Everybody, chill out.
Let's all just go nice and slow.
Why is the music so epic?
Oh!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh my god.
They're already...
They're already really coming for my head.
I got sixty-ninth and they're like, you're a threat.
We won't let you get ahead any longer.
That was your highest score today, Minto.
Is what the boss music is saying.
Oh!
I'm scared.
I'm really scared right now.
I'm worried about my complexion.
Oh gosh.
Oh!
There we go.
Okay.
Build flat.
But it's really hard.
Oh!
Okay.
Flat is just...
Oh!
I already messed up.
I'm building flat.
Just get it out of here.
And nicely.
And evenly.
Look at that.
Da da.
Why is this like JoJo ass music?
What's going on?
Oh.
No.
Don't touch me.
Oh.
Ah!
Ah yeah.
Ah yeah!
Oh!
Wait.
What?
What's?
Oh.
What did I die at, everybody?
What did I die
at?
What do you take me for?
102...
This is literal hell!
This is what the final boss music is for!
Look at him!
He's building up his own Ds!
He's making two of them!
I'm literally crying.
WIPE HIS ASS!
He's gonna make it!
He's gonna make it out alive!
Why are you crying?
Because I'm so moved!
Wouldn't you be?
I'm so...
We're watching an artist at work!
It's true!
Oh my god, I can't stop crying.
This is peak.
Wait, he died?
Oh my god, wait, when did that happen?
HAHAHAHAHA!
But you were supposed to...
You killed me!
You can't kill me and then not win!
Game!
I made top 100!
Unrelated, but in the new Dragon Ball Sparking Zero game, one of the lines Goku says when you go in Super Saiyan is, Kept you waiting, huh?
I saw that!
I did see that.
The new game looks awesome.
Thank you!
Chuuu!
Didn't expect Castlevania music in a block.
I got 69?
Really?
I'll be the judge.
Oh, you really did.
But next to baby butt cheeks.
HAHAHAHAHA!
My birthday ended days ago, but it's never too late.
Cazaleo!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Cazaleo.
Happy birthday.
Wow, who got last?
Oh, I think these people just deseed?
Gummy Crow.
You got last.
Okay.
I can chat now, can't I?
Hello.
I'm getting that badge.
Me too.
HAHAHAHAHA!
You're awesome!
Wow, thank you!
New here, playing Tetria with you is so fun.
Work has been slow, so I'm slipping in some games in between.
But I'm enjoying your vibes.
So have a sub and a dono.
What?
No way!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I appreciate it.
Good luck with work!
You can use the controller here?
Oh my gosh, do we have people doing the rolling method?
You know, where they hold it and then they go...
With their fingies?
No way.
Man, man, you're going down.
I'm already down.
Don't put me any further.
Grape is back.
Oh my gosh, I remember this!
Okay, Grape.
Let's see what you can do.
Can you get...
Wait, so do you get a badge if you just win a game?
Or do you have to win the entire room?
Because...
That'd be crazy.
OSK is in the lobby.
He's the founder...
Of...
Of Tetrio?
Oh no!
What's happening here?
I hear that whenever OSK is in the room with you, crazy things may happen.
Brace yourself.
Hi!
I'm gonna start now!
I'm scared!
Go!
Faster!
We must be faster!
This music is killing my vibe, though.
This music is killing my vibe!
OSK, I demand you take it out the setlist!
Remove it!
If you can hear me!
I don't...
I can't...
Oh no!
No!
Wait!
I don't mean it!
I didn't mean it!
Please!
It's...
God, if there is...
I was
gonna say, if there is a John Tetris out there, please...
Let me live!
It's okay.
Oh, we're back to Grape.
MintSuperfan9000 got KO'd.
Look at them!
They're just dropping like flies!
Grape is taking out everybody!
I died instantly.
It's okay, me too, because I was too busy laughing.
It's the song, everybody.
It's the song.
Insult my soundtrack choice, will you?
Streamer laughing is game interference and got me killed.
What are you talking about?
Oh my god, Grape.
You're only ranked...
You're only placement 62-1.
Come on.
Get better, man.
Get better.
Oh!
Oh, good.
Almost three pieces per second.
That's insanity.
Did you mess up?
No, I didn't.
Of course not.
Grape, nah.
I'd win.
For real.
Wait.
Oh my god!
You can do that?
Oh,
Minty Fresh!
Guy!
Like I said, guys.
I'm not good at Tetris.
But it's all about...
It's all about not taking yourself seriously and just having a good time, you know?
Is the...
What's the...
Is the guy in here?
Oh, Baby Island!
Wow.
They're actually, like, getting better.
So, like, the games are longer now.
You know?
Usually, it's, like...
It was down to, like...
Oh!
Were you teasing us?
You little tease.
Oh!
It's getting really serious!
It's getting hot!
Oh!
Boom!
Tetris for Baby Island!
Oh!
Ow!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Boom!
Tetris!
Oh!
They're so sweaty.
Sushi Man's going crazy.
Everybody here.
Oh!
How's the sound, by the way, guys?
What?
I think Baby Island's got him on speed.
Yeah.
Oh!
Maybe?
On game!
Oh!
Um...
Sound is good?
Okay!
Thank you.
Okay.
Transform now.
Good.
Happy birthday!
suspent 77af
Oh, good.
So they have Yeah.
I locked in the 34th.
No way!
You're pulling my leg!
You're there!
Shouse!
289, don't look!
One day we need to make...
Anybody below 100...
We need to... You can't join unless you're below 100.
In rank.
Oh man.
If you want I could set the game mode to battle royale under the match tab.
It's a bit more beginner friendly.
Oh thank you!
I could set the game mode to battle royale.
Do we want to try that?
I don't mind it being not beginner friendly.
But...
Yeah, you know what?
We do have a big lobby.
So let's try doing that.
Yeah.
Thank you always, Kate!
Let me see.
Just in case...
Thank you!
Yeah, let's try it.
Aw, so nice!
Don't forget to save.
Oh, thank you.
Room configuration updated!
So now it's...
It's...
Like, room v.
room, right?
Wait, first to...
Amount of rank...
Wait, how does this work actually?
Wait...
Where do we drop them?
Do 4 by 100...
No...
Wait...
Just leave it as is?
Okay.
Let's start it.
Let's see how it goes.
Let's see what happens.
Why is the...
Why is the room number keep going up?
Oh, this is so cute.
See, this is the chill.
You know, everybody.
We were talking about.
It's...
Tetris is no...
Big deal, yo, everyone.
Tetris is no big deal, yo.
I gotta be fast.
I gotta be faster.
And I gotta not second guess my...
My...
Okay, build.
I need to not just take down.
I need to build.
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
Build, build.
Build, build, build, build.
Build, build, build.
Oh, build.
This looks sad.
Build, build, build.
Build, build, build, build, build, build, build, build, build, build.
Destroy!
I don't know who I just took out.
Probably some sad sap.
Didn't even know what was gonna hit him.
But, boom, coming with the made Minto.
Perfect.
What was that?
Don't target me.
I'm the streamer.
Oh my gosh.
Don't target me!
I'm the streamer!
Please!
Oh shoot.
I'm okay everybody.
I'm fine.
Maybe.
Maybe I'm okay.
Oh my gosh.
This is forcing me to really get good, isn't it?
Yes sir!
Yes sir.
No sir.
Oh no sir!
No sir!
No.
No sir.
Oh no sir.
No no sir.
Oh shoot!
Shoot sir!
Oh sir sir.
Oh I'm sorry sir.
I'm sorry sir.
Oh gosh.
No.
Yes sir.
I live sir.
I live sir!
How did I make it out?
Oh shoot.
I think I... You guys, I think I've... I think I...
Sad music is really killing me right now.
I threw for real.
Top 100 though.
Yippee!
I'm really sweaty.
Got to love your freestyle rap.
That was a rollercoaster of emotions.
Is Mayoshi PP Island in this?
Old man yaoi.
Oh!
Oh he's came right there!
I see PP.
There's Fast Bulba.
Woohoo!
Woohoo lol.
Funny coincidence I arrived back home from Japan same day of your return stream.
Sadly no main cafe but I loved being at the Kirby Cafe!
Woo!
Nice!
How many people were... 367?
I think?
Speedy Fire welcome back!
Ugh.
The game just gets too fast.
Yeah.
Uh oh.
Oh.
You can fix this.
The way your mood changes playing Tetris is like watching the I'm a Genius Oh No meme on loop.
What's that meme?
Back to lurking.
Thank you!
The L-turns are always so... I know, right?
That's the things that I don't expect.
The L-turns.
They're really crazy.
Can you do that in normal Tetris?
Or like...
Because I've never... I mean, I don't watch so much Tetris stuff but...
Mostly T.
Okay.
You can do it in modern Tetris now.
Wow!
No, I know T-spins.
L-turns though aren't real.
T-spins.
Okay, I know the T-spins are real.
Yeah.
In Tetris 99, you can.
In NES Tetris, no.
T-spins aren't real and can't hurt you.
Hell no, this isn't me playing.
I wouldn't be able to talk and play like this.
So delicate.
Rinto is so good.
Play
like this without talking?
Probably.
I can probably play... I can probably play 50 times better than this guy without talking.
And also off stream.
I can play 50 times better than this guy off stream.
Streamer debuff.
Yeah.
I get... I get a little bit of anxiety.
The... you know, you guys watching just really makes me anxious and nervous and sweaty.
If she wasn't streaming, she'd be number one Tetris.
That's true.
Pikachu, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
10 people left.
Oh, Pee Pee Island.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, Pee Pee Island.
Oh.
They're throwing on purpose because you told them to?
What!
He fought himself!
I leveled up.
I want to say that you're awesome.
Thank you, Magister!
I got 88th, though.
Actually, that's not so bad.
I thought I was just top 100, but I got 88th.
I mean, I am top 100, but like...
Nice!
I'll take it.
Especially because I got taken down by the frickin' winner!
You frickin' fricksa!
At 300+, that's good.
Yeah!
It's not bad, right?
Yippee!
I don't understand this game mode, though.
I don't really understand it.
There was some desync.
FigJam!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
I didn't K-O-O-S-K.
So sad.
Seems like Tetris 99, maybe.
Well, basically works the same as Tetris 99, but without the garbage cap.
Ah, okay, okay.
Well, cool!
Oh my gosh, we're almost to 400 people in here!
This is wild!
Cosmic down!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Holy cow!
Alright.
Message... about... now.
Huh?
About who, huh?
What, what?
About now.
Hello?
Hahahaha!
Huh?
Okay, anyway.
Okay, let's start the game!
378!
Holy moly.
I died!
Beep!
Wah!
Ooh!
Mysterious!
Mysterious...
I could do a T-spin right there.
Okay, I have to handle myself appropriately.
Hold on!
I'm setting up!
Gosh!
Wait.
Oh, I messed it up.
Never mind!
Hold on, please!
Please!
No!
God!
Let me fix this!
Okay!
Hold on!
I just wanted to...
I wanted to be like the cool kids, man!
This is torture!
Oh, okay.
Oh, no!
Like this?
Ah, I think I'm in trouble.
Guys, I think I'm in trouble.
I think I'm in trouble.
I didn't even get to play!
I tried.
There was an attempt.
Lying too close to the sun on that one.
Maybe this isn't the best place to...
To, you know... practice.
Hahaha!
Maybe Battle Royale isn't better for noobs.
OSK really...
Just totally overestimated my skill level.
It's okay, though.
This is how you get better.
By playing against the real good people.
It's true, though.
But it's my fault.
I haven't played in literal years.
So...
It's all my fault.
Who else is in here?
Oh!
You got disturbed!
How do you even see with those shades?
I'm telling you.
With my instincts.
They're not very sharp, though.
Fun for Tetris FX connected on Steam.
Oh!
Tetris FX...
Is that the one, the really chill one that takes you through time and space?
No, that's...
Wait.
No, that is the Tetris FX, isn't it?
Isn't that Tetris FX?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But
for Puyo Puyo Tetris...
I am so garbage at Puyo Puyo, though.
If you want to see even more pain than this today...
You can play Tetris FX, that movie with...
Ashton Kutcher?
You can play Tetris FX in VR!
I remember, like, you go through the ocean and there's like...
Space...
What's the word?
Space Whales.
I like Tetris with Cardcaptor, Sakura...
Fix it!
It's a super!
Akasupa!
Gives me such a throwback to be able to play with you in chat since...
Since last time, many years ago.
Here's my first Akasupa since I wasn't able back then.
Thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I know, it is a bit of a throwback though, isn't it?
Not even a bit of a throwback.
Like, a lot of a throwback.
Is Minta Pro at Honey Pop?
Oh yeah.
Don't you know it.
Dang!
Dave is really holding his own up in here.
I saw you play detective games.
I think you'd like Tangle Tower on Steam.
It's a murder mystery.
Thanks for the...
For the suggestion.
That wasn't your fault.
I've never felt so inadequate as a gamer.
Honey Pop's dream win.
When I decide that I no longer need this channel, I guess.
I think YouTube would ban me, wouldn't they?
Even I...
There's like a save for work version though, isn't there?
But I still think that I would...
I think like even on Twitch, even if you play the save for work one...
You can play a patch on YouTube?
No way.
Really?
Sushi Man is still in it.
Remilia!
That's my Oshii right there.
Wait.
Remilia?
Remilia, where'd you go?
Yeah, these people are crazy good.
Sushi Man said, nope.
And then the game said, nope.
Back at him.
Dang.
That was such a good comeback though at first.
How is this still humanly possible?
You get a badge if you KO OSK in any game.
So his presence is probably luring players.
I did know about the badge, but I guess you're right.
That maybe people are like, uh-huh, I want the badge.
Oh my gosh, Minto Room's so popular!
It's a party up in here, baby!
I mean, it's a...
It's like a...
I mean, it's a battle royale party.
It's a bloodbath up in here.
Soap party!
With bath!
I mean, with blood!
Whoa!
Committed to membership.
Thanks for inventing, Tetris.
Thanks, PaperBuzz!
Oh!
281.
That was my mess up though.
It really was.
That was my mess up.
Goth Girl Slayer!
But she couldn't slay.
I think...
Couldn't slay in Tetrio.
So sad.
GG, everybody.
Practically a more beginner-friendly game mode, but when you have a bunch of people from the highest ranks in the lobby, beginner-friendly is relative.
Yeah, makes sense.
No, I'm still having fun though.
I don't really care if really good people come in.
Just survived the worst exam of my life and I want to celebrate!
Let's go!
Your ghost trick streams gave me life.
I'm so happy!
Congrats on finishing your exam!
Okay.
I got 22nd.
I saw you up in there, Amelia!
I totally saw you.
I was like, yo!
I got 49th.
It's fun to play Tetris with you again.
Yeah!
Alright.
It was huge fun.
Thank you!
Thanks.
I think people are leaving.
Maybe because OSK left.
Go you!
Pinning message is just slash A.
Message.
I am mint.
Wow!
Oh, cool!
That's what I wrote.
I'm mint.
I'm almost sweating.
I am sweating.
Messing around with the game presets.
I think I...
I think things are pretty interesting in of itself.
Especially with my level, you know?
Sorry for misleading you.
New Godzilla.
Minus one.
It's not only on Netflix.
Also on all streaming services.
Oh!
Let's go!
Now I can finally watch it.
Okie dokie!
Let's start the game.
I'm guessing...
Do lobbies not get this very...
This big very often?
It's probably...
It's probably exciting for even the bigger players too.
Because they get to play with a lot of different people.
Just a lot of people in general, you know?
So...
You know.
It's fun for everybody.
I'd say.
It's just a big old party room.
Whoa!
Oh!
No!
Please!
God!
No!
Please!
God!
No!
Please!
I'm too slow at this!
Ah!
Please!
Please God!
Please Tetris God!
John Tetris!
Ah!
There's no way I can recover from...
Oh!
I killed someone!
Sorry.
I...
Hi!
Me!
Oh!
I KO'd somebody!
I'm...
I'm a monster!
I'm a monster now!
Oh no!
No!
Please!
That doesn't...
That doesn't make me a target!
Please!
Please God!
No!
Please!
Oh!
No!
I'm throwing!
I'm throwing for real!
The pressure is too strong!
I'm...
I'm too...
I'm too good at the game now!
Karma for killing so many!
Monster Minto!
Dude came back at all I did!
How does the blood taste, man?
Delicious!
You can now call me vamp.
Not because I'm a vampire.
How can you miss twice, Minto?
I'm telling you!
The pressure is too great!
I can't live with myself...
Well, I'm not living at all, but...
I can't...
I can't take this pressure of knowing that the creator of the website is watching me.
Potentially.
Oh, my goodness gracious.
Remilia!
I believe in you.
That's my toho oshi right there.
Grape slu...
Grape is back!
Oh, no.
I'm not jinxing Remilia.
These guys are so fast, I know, right?
They're crazy good.
I'm gonna be there one day.
Thanks, Mid, for KO'ing me.
I'm going to cry!
You're welcome Sir9!
Sir9!
I bet it was your honor.
Your pleasure.
Remy's theme is playing in my head right now.
With the Castlevania music, it's kind of perfect.
Love the certified freak phantom glasses.
Thank you!
Is this real?
Chat, is this real?
When playing Tetris, the goal isn't to win.
The goal is to be eliminated by me.
I think that will probably be my only elimination today.
I'm sorry to say.
They caused a natural...
They caused nature to respond to the thunder!
They had 23 combo!
Have you ever played any of the Castlevania games before?
I have!
I like them.
Hippie!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Zeus!
Zeus Caboose!
Come on, Zeus Caboose!
The games are getting longer and longer.
Now we're stuck at 40 people.
The Zeus is loose!
30 combo caused the thunder!
Have you seen the old Metal Gear Solid Flash video called Crab Battle?
I have!
When I was playing MGS3...
A bunch of people kept recommending it to me.
The Zeus got Caboosed!
Lore!
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Tetris with my Oshi is scary but fun this time.
It used to still... you know, it used to be pretty intense back in the day too.
But I think... I think we've reached new levels.
I think not only have people reached new heights...
But so have the lobbies.
I was practicing most of today in preparation for this stream.
And you did really well.
You've been doing really well.
They're dancing?
My bad for KOing you this round before this one.
Oh, the round before this one.
No worries, Lore!
No worries.
It's all in the game.
Holy cow!
Sushi Man took them out!
The sushi is raw!
Fresh from the sea!
Hey boss, just quit my job.
By cussing at my boss earlier.
Problem is, I don't have much money.
Should I come back and pretend like nothing happened?
Yeah!
I'm sure he'll just say it was a dream.
Also, you could go up to him and be like, chat, is this real?
And he'll say no.
It's real.
There's hope to the most cracked on PC.
I'm just gaslighting.
Say it never happened.
This person has no life and no game.
I talk so much shit for someone that can't...
I can't hold
my own.
I don't think Sushi Man has won a game yet.
Aw...
G-Z-I!
Oh my goodness.
That was so close.
I leveled up to level 7.
What was I?
215?
There I am.
Rest in peace, Sushi Man.
Yeah.
Sheesh.
I got 35 on that one.
Nice!
And Draco6 for the tag gifted!
I achieved my mission of pushing Mint's ranking up by one.
Stop.
No.
Alright.
Thanks, John Ronaldo!
Mint will win this one for sure.
Yeah!
I'm...
I'm using tilt controls!
I even pinned my message.
Okay, the lobby's going down just a little bit, so maybe this is our chance, you guys.
350 players!
What days will you be attending Anime Fest?
I think, like, every single day.
Not even lying.
They were like, can you attend, like, every day?
And I was like, um...
That's a lot of days.
Hey, hey.
Hey, we just started.
Not cool, not cool.
Not cool.
We just started.
Hey, hey, not cool.
Not cool, not cool.
Get out of here.
I'm holding my own.
This is a doggy dog.
No world out here, please!
Please!
Gosh,
please!
Oh gosh, it's such a doggy dog world!
No!
This is murder.
This is a murder!
Oh my gosh, hey guys!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Holy cow!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go get some more water real quick, though, guys.
I'll be right back.
I will be...
BRB.
You guys can watch, uh, Nesulu.
It's a doggy dog world out there.
I pray you survive the exorcisms to come be well.
Thank you for the peek.
Thank you.
I'll be right back.
I'm 100% getting worse each round.
No, it's not you!
I think people are getting better!
All the better people are coming into the lobby, for real.
I also bought a slice of pizza.
It's cold.
Gyro now goes here!
Hello!
Blue super chat.
I discovered you with that drill.
Why are you so good at this?
I'm just a really talented...
Look, Ma!
No hands!
There's a doggy dog world out here.
That's what this song should be called.
Doggy dog world.
Doesn't it have some super doggy dog vibes?
Professional observer.
Sign me up for GDQ.
I'll observe all your games.
I feel more like a cool cat listening to this.
You're so right.
Sorry, I'll react more.
Once I've done my pizza.
How often does the guy play Tetris for people to get so excited to try and get the badge?
I imagine he's also so good, you know?
Mint
won't read this.
Dill pickle and chicken on white sauce is the best pizza.
Awesome!
Oh, he rarely joins public rooms.
The
exam's starting next week.
No!
You got this!
White bear butts!
Chicken and white sauce.
Sounds like you made like a weird chicken alfredo.
I ran a game at AGDQ 2020.
What'd you run?
What one?
I guess I would kinda dox you though.
Freaking rad looking phantom right there.
Can
you think of a pizza?
I don't know if you can get out of that one, buddy.
A pizza?
It's just a cheese pizza.
That's it.
I ran Battletoads Game Boy on Super Game Boy?
I thought Battletoads wasn't a real game.
A
little messy there, Tiana.
Oh, you got this though.
I have no room to talk.
What the hell am I trying to get commentary for?
It's real?
I'll call GameStop and check if it's real.
It's actually real?
No way.
I was screwed over by the new lagless monitors they wanted.
Oh.
I didn't want to make it difficult for them to set up a CRT.
Ah.
This will get interesting.
It's not for like the record though.
It's for the charity.
Joy, thank you for the pink.
Thank you so much.
The Kingdom Hearts PC release is real.
You're right.
Cookie!
I don't think blood can get out of this one.
Ooh.
Yeah, you're right.
Kingdom Hearts is on Steam now.
That's crazy.
830 lines sent.
A flood sent over a thou- This person sent 1,200 lines!
1,500 lines!
Sushi Man is really fast.
Like, stinking fast.
Would I ever stream Kingdom Hearts?
Probably not.
If I were to stream Kingdom Hearts...
I honestly only have any interest in the first two games.
So...
I don't think I would stream them, to be honest.
Good morning.
Good morning!
GG Mint.
Uh, yeah.
G-G-G-G-G.
Yeah.
GG.
Kingdom Hearts 2 is the best Kingdom Hearts for sure.
I agree.
It's my favorite.
I remember!
Like...
Killing off Sephiroth.
Like, trying that fight over and over and over again.
Until I finally beat him.
Yeah...
Okay.
How is everyone so fast?
Um...
Go... wait.
Slime?
Go easy on me.
Please-y.
Go easy on me, please-y!
Hahahaha!
Here we go!
No.
Easy, please-y!
Oh, look!
We're losing people!
Thank goodness.
I mean...
Oh, no!
My room is less popular!
Oh, this is so nice.
This is so nice.
When are they dropping the Tetrio soundtrack, huh?
This is so awesome.
Oh.
Hey!
Whoa!
Why is it already so full?
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
I messed up.
Oh.
There we go.
Ah!
Come on, man!
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
I gotta go faster.
I gotta go...
Maybe...
Maybe we should let the good people have their own room, right?
Oh, shoot.
Okay.
Get me out of here, please!
Oh, gosh!
Oh.
I just...
Okay.
And, uh...
My
emplacement's all over the place, everybody!
I think they left me alone.
Let's go.
Ah!
No, please.
Please!
Ow!
You know what?
I'm gonna go into Zen mode.
I'm practicing, you guys.
I'm getting...
I gotta get faster.
Okay.
Oh.
Practice speed.
Practice speed and placement.
Actually, it doesn't matter where you place.
It kinda matters where you place.
But it doesn't matter as long as you're fast about it.
You can get yourself out of anything.
As long as you're fast about it...
Why is the music so funky?
Oh, I almost said monkey because I was saying music and funky, but now I'm thinking about balloons!
What was I saying?
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't... faster.
Faster.
Faster, faster.
See, I can get myself out of that.
Easy peasy.
No worries.
Just gotta be fast.
See, look at that.
Yeah!
Look at that!
See?
It doesn't matter how bad you are, as long as you're fast about it.
It's okay.
Everybody makes mistakes.
Everybody has those days.
There we go.
Just slide that right in there.
Little pickle.
Everybody has these days.
Oh, I made another mistake.
Everybody makes mistakes.
Everybody has these days.
Maybe it does matter.
Maybe I was... maybe I had full-on colpium.
No.
Be bad quickly.
Get guided, boss.
Sounds like straight-up visual novel music.
Oh.
It's okay.
I'm in a visual novel now.
And it's... somebody will die.
It probably was me.
I'm already dead.
This is it.
This is my... this is my popular era.
This is my sexy arc!
Oh, no.
I died.
The music is so sad.
Oh, no.
Oh.
That's okay.
The
ladies love me!
I think.
Uh-oh.
How am I going to get myself out of this pickle?
With Long Boy!
Long Boy to the rescue!
Long Boy!
See?
Now, if nobody was attacking me...
I'd totally be fine in Tetris.
I am my own worst enemy.
Oh, no.
I died again.
Okay.
This is a good warm-up.
This is a good warm-up, right?
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, I think I messed that up.
But that's fine.
L... L... L...
Minto.
Sometimes when the orange and the mint blocks go next to each other, they kind of look like brown.
You know?
An hour and a half out?
Wait!
An hour and a half late for a party?
Go have fun!
You're going to a... party.
T.F.T.I.
But also...
Oh!
Wait!
What?
Why is the game attacking me?
This is zen mode!
Why am I getting attacked in zen mode?
Where's the zen?
What's going on?
Is it because people are angry that I haven't made a new lobby?
A new room?
Is that what's going on?
Is the game over?
I'm so confused!
Why am I getting attacked in zen mode?
Why is my game haunted?
Oh!
I messed up!
I am my own worst enemy, truly.
Hi raiders!
Hello!
I couldn't say the name.
I think it was alien.
Thank you for the raid!
Oh my god!
I'm getting attacked!
What is happening?
Guys,
it's over for me.
Even zen mode thinks I suck.
Even zen mode is just like, just give up.
No!
I'm gonna have my shounen anime arc!
Please!
Just let me prove it to you!
Saki, thanks for the five gifts!
Return to venue!
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
We can start.
I was getting attacked?
See, I was getting attacked in zen mode.
Was I actually?
Oh shoot, I need to pay attention.
I need to pay attention.
Fast.
I've trained for this.
Oh!
No!
Wait.
Let's get out of here.
Gosh, this soundtrack is so nostalgic though.
I remember this from when I used to play.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Take that!
Oh wait.
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
I almost had it.
I'm just a little silly sometimes.
Don't worry about it, guys.
No!
No, please!
It's not okay!
Everything is bad!
I got KO'd by a weeb!
The soundtrack gives visual novel to my games.
Guys, I was so zenned out.
I wasn't even looking at you guys.
I wasn't looking at anything.
I was just in the zen.
I was just...
Why are they so stinky?
It's
all zenned out.
In this lobby, you're always KO'd by a weeb.
True.
Anyway,
sorry about that.
Oof.
Familiar is scary.
I think Sushi Man is scarier.
Some of these people have like cra...
Oh, Grape is back.
They have crazy...
Oh, OSK is still here.
They have crazy speed.
Say
something really crazy for the clip.
What?
Cut for a bit.
How many games have you won?
Of course!
I'm winning every game because I'm playing with you guys.
Obviously.
Not
the tease.
Not the tease spin.
When they...
When they kind of like wobble it in there.
They're just like, do you want me to place it?
It's called the tease spin.
Yeah,
this is Remilia's Scarlet Reel.
They would be better, but they're playing from Gensokyo.
So, she's got some lag, you know.
Can change settings.
The pang.
Tetris Noobie.
Get out of here.
You wouldn't be top 40 then.
We can watch the king.
She didn't want to win, it seems.
Yeah, that's okay.
Oh.
You got him next time.
Get him next time, Tiger.
That happened to me too.
Maybe I'm just as good.
Oh.
Someone gets a badge.
Where do you see the badge at?
The feeling of being subjected.
Sorry.
Everybody
I watch wins.
The curse of observation.
Kazanya Boy.
Oh.
I was going to say, how are you surviving this?
Yeah, it's...
Maybe I'll take off my glasses.
I might do better, you know.
See, I told you.
I only watch the winners.
I told you.
He really hates Mondays.
That's why he's so happy it's Friday.
Duh.
162.
I guess it could be worse, right?
Where am I?
Oh.
There I am.
You were supposed to get out!
GG.
GG is everybody.
Can you clone yourself some multiple people?
Alrighty.
Hmm.
And Phantom, if you're reading this...
I...
I am.
I am!
I'm reading both chats.
Mini-boy!
Thanks for two months!
GG's.
I always wonder why I added the O.S.K.
badge.
Where do you see the badge?
Oh, it may be up in here.
Nice!
Cool!
Let's have... a fun time.
Made me... armpits?
No.
Let's have a bad time.
Can you sleep in GG?
Going to watch from bed with cat.
I want to watch in bed with cat.
Let's have a bad time.
Made Mint's room.
Get out of my room, you freaks!
You weirdos.
What are you doing in my room, huh?
Whoa, whoa, already?
Please.
Show some mercy.
Show some mercy, please.
Please.
Please, on this floor, so...
Okay.
Got out of that for now.
Out of that for now.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Wait.
You know what?
That works.
I could set up a T-spin there, but I'm too nervous.
I'm too nervous.
No!
Don't do this.
Please.
There.
I got rid of it.
Oh, my gosh.
I got rid of it!
Uh-oh.
I don't know if I can get rid of this, though.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Ha!
We did it.
Oh...
Oh, it's the same.
Everything is just bleak and sad.
Oh, no, no, wait, no, please!
Don't do this to me!
No!
That was too slow.
He did one shot at me.
How the heck?
You got killed, man.
Oh, no!
You got killed, you got killed!
Look, that guy... if that guy targets you...
Rest in...
That guy targets you, rest in pieces.
You're stacking pretty high, so no surprise.
I know.
I was trying to get it out.
I try to keep myself low, but I know you gotta stack high to retaliate.
You know?
But I'm not fast enough to return the hits.
So...
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
I'm recovering from...
From the sea virus.
But I'm negative now.
I can return to being a functioning member of society.
Wait, where'd Picnic go?
Ray and
Rex!
Metal Gear Rex!
We have Metal Gear Ray and Metal Gear Rex...
Right next to each other.
Hey there, Negative.
I have Goatee.
No, I don't.
Oh, a Goatee!
Oh, sheesh.
Anyway...
I thought I've just read it wrong.
I was like...
That doesn't even make any sense.
How would I have that?
It's not something you have, I don't think.
I got KO'd by OSK.
It's time to put the freaky glasses back on.
Okay, Mom.
Is that better?
Put those freak glasses...
I'm not a freak!
My name is Mid Phantom!
And Wins Not Freak Phantom!
I don't think anyone can match her.
My name is Mid Phantom!
Barely anybody even knows my name, has it?
We can't change it.
I'm sorry.
It's FFF.
Freaky Phantom Friday!
How to hold?
In this game, I'm pretty sure it's Shift, right?
Shift is hold, right?
Shift or C?
Oh, it defaults to C.
Oh, I see, I see.
I see!
I see, I see!
He's on your boy!
Congrats for first badge!
I
have a badge?
Wait, someone said congrats on your first badge!
Wait, is Remilia here too?
Zeus!
Peepy Island.
Sushi.
We got all the...
We have all the regulars up at the top.
Fast
for my 5 business day replay.
Too real.
Small
thing in my chest.
Flood just flooded them!
Flood flooded them!
Holy moly.
I got 148.
Badge up!
Is
this...
This is my badge?
I got a badge!
Yippee!
145?
Oh wait, I'm not so low.
Alright.
Yeah.
One...
Freak Phantom!
Wait, Garlimaw.
Cool.
G...
Oh, I can't type.
Get out of here.
Don't add me to your friends list.
Now you can maul and tilt in...
Jolica gets out there.
Haha.
G.
You...
You will never...
Wait...
You will never KO OSK.
Start the game.
Hahaha.
I gotta rile them up a little bit, you know.
I don't think they're...
I don't think they're being sweaty enough here, you know.
I don't think...
We gotta...
We gotta put a little bit more competition into this.
Oh...
Oops.
Oh shoot.
Shoot.
Hey, hey, hey!
I mean, yeah, that's what I wanted!
Oh,
it hurts.
Okay.
This is fine, probably.
Yeah!
That's fine!
Probably!
Oh, shoot.
I'm throwing.
I'm throwing for real?
No!
I'm gonna die.
This is where I die!
Freak phantom!
I'm from Colombia!
Let's go
for two months!
Thank you!
I didn't even place 200.
So sad.
Couldn't match the freak.
Come back after two hours of overtime for a good stream!
Welcome!
Otsu!
Otsu Otsu.
Otsu is a trilingual maid.
Yes!
I like it!
Hello.
How are you?
Very good, thank you.
I love you.
I'm... I'm Minto.
I don't like it.
I'm Minto.
Hello, Minto.
Hello.
Oh, hello.
Hi, Minto.
Hello.
Hello, Minto.
We're freaking here!
This guy...
This guy KO'd me.
Everyone target the FIFO!
Target the FIFO!
FIFI FOFUM!
I smell your death on the line.
Ring ring, pick up the phone.
It's death calling.
Oh, yeah, yeah, there we go.
That didn't rhyme.
What if my dear friend Noko-tan was freaky and said, Freak-a-noko-noko-noko-noko-tan-tan.
Wow, what if?
That would be cra- Oh no, it's Flood!
It's our winner!
It's the champion!
He's so fast.
Flood is crazy.
I think though, maybe the fastest is Tsushima.
But he's fast, but he's messy, you know?
Oh.
Oh, it's King.
The King!
Someone take this guy out!
You'll get a badge!
You'll get a badge.
I'll gift it to you.
I'll personally give you a badge.
Oh, almost save.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, buddy.
My chronos!
Here's your badge!
There's your badge!
Freak phantom!
Certified freak.
Whee!
You're a certified freak!
Freak!
Oh, see?
The long boys are the same color!
So it's perfect.
Certified freak.
Seven days a week.
Creepy island.
My
throat is actually really hurting today.
So I might just do a few...
Because I've been coughing a lot.
I might just do a few more games.
Tetris is very relaxing.
That's why I feel like I need a shower after this.
Oh!
Sushi Man!
Will Sushi Man finally get a win?
Oh my god, the recovery!
We're watching two gods go against each other.
This is insane.
Sushi Man gets a win!
No way!
Sushi Man's crazy!
Oh, I almost made it to 200.
GG's!
Get better soon, man.
Thank you!
I will, I will.
Tomorrow...
I plan on playing...
If you thought this was a callback...
Wait until tomorrow!
I'm playing Doom 64!
Doom 64!
But I'm actually playing Doom 64 tomorrow.
So...
Hello!
No!
Okay.
What's the next one?
Did
you see the prequel for the new...
Or the trailer.
It's a prequel!
Oh my goodness.
What a sweet sounding soundtrack.
Surely nothing bad can happen in this game...
If the soundtrack is so cute and sweet.
Right?
I
should probably not build up anymore.
Oh no.
This is why I shouldn't build up anymore!
Oh no, please!
Please, Long Boy, save me!
Long Boy!
Long Boy, won't you come down?
Thank you, Long Boy.
You saved me.
Long Boy!
Goodness.
No.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Long Boy!
Long Boy, save me!
Long
Boy, I believe.
This is it.
Oh no.
Oh.
Shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Long Boy.
I'll use you...
In my final moments.
In my...
Oh, shoot.
Long Boy.
Sad anime scene music happening right now.
I know sad music.
I'm out.
So sad.
I got a little village child in a medieval anime.
Who's about to die.
Wow!
Did you see how the colors are so cool?
When
the left bar is just all red.
Sad times.
Oh, did she read my comments?
Shut up!
I'll be okay.
Okay, I have some medicine that I can take, but I ran out of my cold medicine, because that's what I was taking before, but I have some throat stuff that I can take, or learning the tragic back story of a heroine.
She says, all I ever wanted to do was be loved.
All I wanted was a family that would love me.
But alas, I must fight in this cruel world, in this war that I didn't ask for.
Just like Himmel the Hero.
Himmel the Hero.
That's a name I haven't heard in a long time.
Himmel the Hero would have given us Longboy.
I think Himmel the Hero is Longboy.
If it were just a little light blue.
Stop dancing!
Sounds
like something out of Final Fantasy XVI.
He was a good friend.
Himmel the Hero.
He wasn't just a friend, he was a hero.
Get it right.
It's in his name.
He wasn't Himmel the Friend.
He was Himmel the Hero.
He wasn't just a friend, he was Himmel the Hero.
How dare you disgrace his legacy like that.
Just don't friendzone him like that.
I know Free Ren did, but she still called him by his title.
I'm so excited for when more Free Ren comes out.
I've just been thinking about it like every day.
I'm just like, when will we get more Free Ren?
Please.
But we are getting, what, the set new season of Oshinoko.
I'm kind of excited about that.
Someone stole my mood ring.
You the booster!
Thank you!
I haven't watched Dungeon Mist yet.
I know a lot of people really like that show.
Usually I don't like watching shows about food because they make me hungry.
Like I watched Food Wars.
I didn't finish it.
I eventually stopped watching.
I don't remember what season.
I think maybe I only watched the first season.
It's the best anime of the season.
Watch it while eating.
But my food never tastes so good.
Like it's theirs, you know?
I did see though, like today it got confirmed, the second season or something, right?
Like it was very recent.
Or yesterday or...
Oh,
I know Blue Archive, the anime.
But I still play every day.
Dungeon Mist is a trigger show?
No way.
Should I get, bring Giant Free Ren instead of Giant Doki next time we meet in Greenwood?
Yes!
Actually, I also really want the Giant Free Ren plushie.
My hands need a Tetris break.
Oh, do it!
Cronos!
They're the one who knocked out OSK before.
Level up, baby!
114.
Could be worse.
So far Mint has won every single game.
GG.
Maybe next game, maybe LG?
Last game maybe?
One more game?
We can talk a little bit and then I'm gonna head out.
Didn't you lose?
Nope.
I don't know what you're talking about.
LG.
Thank you, Flood, for always posting that.
Press X to doubt?
I pressed X but nothing happened.
I did say I would do this after every round.
Appreciate you.
What happened?
What just happened?
F?
Try pressing harder.
F.
Top 100, baby!
I at least got top 100.
In the very beginning.
Then all the good people came.
So you know what.
Alright.
I'm done.
LG!
Let's hope... Let's aim for... Let's aim for... Let's have no expectations.
Let's have no expectations.
I like this song.
I'm building... I'm building...
I'm building... my empire.
Maybe we can... You know what?
I'm gonna long boy in there.
Might have been a mistake.
It was not a mistake.
I gotta strike first, you guys.
I'm the weakest link.
So I gotta strike first.
I gotta strike first!
I'm sorry, everybody else!
I'm sorry!
I killed you!
You stole me!
Oh my god!
Wait!
No, I... I'm still playing!
I'm still in the game!
I'm sorry!
You stole me!
Oh, shoot!
Uh-oh.
This is it.
Save me, long boy.
Long boy...
I got so...
Karma for some reason.
Do you know what I mean?
He's in there.
He's dangerous.
Where at?
I
like when they just fall down.
So sad.
Thanks for killing me, Yippee!
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
No, I don't think I made it to 100.
I'm so shocked.
They really came for my neck.
Glad I made it one match at least.
Let's go.
I'm so sleepy.
I did this thing.
I have to run fast.
My toes are better than my fingers.
You can make this out of his toes!
I believe in you!
There we go!
Nice save!
There you go!
Himmel the hero out to Himmel the long boy!
Nice save!
Your meds make you creepy?
I don't think so.
But I have to... since their medicine is medicine from Japan...
I have to take... it's like... you have to take three pills three times a day.
It's so much.
And I only had one left.
So I think that's why I'm coughing so much.
Because I have no cough.
Or suppressants anymore.
Yeah, nine a day.
It's insane.
But a lot of Japanese medicine is like that.
Maybe because they put them in low doses, you know?
They don't do like super high doses for one pill.
So...
But it helped so much.
You are the best Tetris player of all time.
Maybe ever.
Thank you!
Yeah, they do low dosages.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Chronos!
Nice save!
Wow!
Professionals are scary, man.
But it's also so fun just watching someone be good at what they do, you know?
I wore the Mintara socks to the store today.
They're a lot more comfortable than I was expecting.
No way!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for gifting me a month of Tetris with the floor.
Thank you so much!
Chai is talking about Among Us and how Mint is gonna win.
Among Us.
Oh, doremi!
That's right.
Oh, here.
Were they in my...
Were they in the lobbies earlier?
I don't recognize the name.
They're a pretty famous Tetris player.
Really?
Of course they're...
One of the best Tetris players in the world?
It's an honor.
Holy cow!
I wonder if it's the real person.
What did I get?
151!
At least 150 or more to see.
To be a Pokmon master is my...
destiny!
Oh my gosh!
I'm Mew!
That's not so bad.
You know what?
I thought I was in like the 200s.
But actually, I'm in 151!
I feel blessed by Doremi's presence.
Lucky game!
Lucky... I KO'd someone.
I got 151.
Almost to the halfway point of getting top 100.
Excuse me!
Even though there was only 200 people.
That's fine though.
There was only 200 people but...
That's okay.
That's a-okay.
Thanks for playing with us.
Toho!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, what's her name?
Is that a...
Um... Clown Piece?
How do you send that?
Yeah, how do you send Clown Piece?
Thanks for dropping by Intetrioman.
Thank you!
Clown Piece!
How do you- How do I send Clown... Oh, Clown Piece.
Clown Piece.
Clown.
Clown Smug.
Oh.
Clown... Smug.
Yippee!
Let's enter!
Clown Smug.
Have fun Tetris.
Tetrio-ing.
And we're out.
Give me one second you guys.
I actually- We will go to the maid cafe.
It's been a while since we've been there so...
It's been a minute.
Oh!
Where am I?
Yippee!
Let me change the music too.
Now I can check all my notifications.
Oh wait.
Wow, I have so many people who added me to their friends list.
How do I...
Okay, close.
One second...
Where is it?
Wait.
One second.
Here.
Wait, where did I save it?
Oh, there.
Where did I save it?
Under
here?
Where?
Maybe I didn't move it there.
I just forgot.
Um...
Oh!
I did.
I'm so silly.
Okay.
Okay!
Thanks for playing with me, guys.
This is Empluance2day6.
I...
Wanted to play.
But I played earlier too.
I played off stream.
I got to like 167.
Wow, clown piece!
Hahaha!
Really, thank you!
Watching these pros play is like watching somebody play Lunatic on Toho.
You're so right.
My brain can't process it.
Thanks for all the games.
Thank you!
Yeah, we really drew in some crazy players, didn't we?
Some really good people came in.
We're like...
Yeah, I guess I'm gonna...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna dominate in here.
That's just what happens though.
That's just what happens, I think.
This is so fun!
I hope you guys had fun too.
Periodically, we'll...
We'll play some more Tetrio.
When I feel like getting beat up, you know?
When I feel like getting beat up, we can play more.
Let's have fun, yeah?
Super entertaining.
I'm glad!
If you've watched, I hope it was entertaining.
If you played, I hope you had fun.
Um...
So, yeah.
Do a private lobby for Membu sometime?
I don't know if that's possible.
I think it is possible.
That's why they had the...
The...
What's the word?
The code at the top.
But I just did an open lobby.
Just a public one.
So, it would be easier.
But next time, you know, we can probably do like a...
Or a private one or something.
Something...
I don't know.
Something like that.
Today, I've learned how vast the ocean is.
Yeah.
It's pretty vast.
We could do a private lobby someday.
Sometime.
How would I do?
I guess I'll just show the thing on stream, right?
Is Tetrio usually this popular?
I don't know.
I only...
Play...
I played it when I was teeny tiny.
If I got a super lobby, if I hit a hundred people, I was like, yeah, wow.
I can't believe I hit a hundred people.
So, I remember I only hit like a super lobby a couple of times.
Very, very rarely.
So, this is a fun experience.
It used to be even smaller.
Oh, my gosh.
Yeah.
When I first debuted, back in 2013.
It's 2020.
I was a teeny baby.
But yeah.
So, it was fine.
It was fun seeing how crazy people can get.
And then I...
I mean, we had some celebrities.
We had the creator of the site, playing along with us.
That's so awesome.
So, yeah.
It was really great.
They grow up pretty fast.
He woke up so fast.
He wanted to know why the servers were on fire.
Sorry, Osuke.
If it caused you any trouble.
No, I'm sure.
I'm sure.
They have had more people in a lobby.
I'm positive of it.
And people.
And they have the capacity to handle it.
I'm sure of it.
So...
Just a little bit.
That trio is so fun because lots of people can join.
It's really good.
I should get some rest though.
For my throat.
Tomorrow...
I play Doom 64.
Sunday I play it on stream.
I don't know what yet.
Next week?
Metal Gear?
Saturday?
Do you know what time?
For stream tomorrow?
4 PM EST.
I might actually... no.
I might do 5 PM EST.
5 PM EST.
So a little... 2 hours earlier than today.
Any reason you're doing so many throwbacks?
I just...
I played Doom 1 and 2.
And...
I don't know.
I'm not quite ready for Doom 3 yet.
So I was like...
I'll play Doom 64.
And...
But I do want to play Doom 3.
I would like to play original Doom 3.
Because it's...
Because I want to play with...
It's like...
You either have your flash...
The lights are off and you either have your flashlight out.
Or you have your gun out.
So it's actually...
A horror game.
But I don't know.
I just felt like going back to Doom.
Just because... I don't know.
Doom 3 is one of my favorites.
Haters welcome.
And then...
Maybe...
I think maybe because...
Because...
The new Doom trailer...
Kind of inspired me.
I'll play up to...
Doom 2016.
And then the new Doom...
Did it have a release date?
What was it called?
Doom...
Oh yeah.
And then there's Doom Eternal.
And...
Wait.
Or is that Doom 2016?
Am I stupid?
Forget Doom.
Embrace DOOM.
The Dark Age.
Thank you.
Dark Ages.
Dark Ages release date.
Sometime in...
2025.
Oh.
So we have...
Quite some time.
I'm wondering if...
Metal Gear is going to get delayed.
Because they haven't put up a...
A...
Release date.
I wonder.
If maybe it'll be...
Delayed.
To like early next year.
Hmm.
I mean someone put up a date for it.
You mean the GameStop one?
But they already clarified that was a...
A mistake.
My favorite about Doom is the music.
Yeah.
Right.
So awesome.
I like the music.
I need more time to perfect the pee pee filter.
Yeah.
I'm not...
Rushing it though.
I'm like yeah.
I'll wait for however long.
I just can't wait to play it.
There's going to be so many more people getting it.
I mean already with the Master Collection.
So many more people...
Have been getting into Metal Gear.
I just hope that they can announce the Volume 2.
And I know it's...
I know it's...
Not confirmed or...
Probably a pipe dream.
But I really hope that they can find a way to...
Get Metal Gear Solid 4 on there.
Hmm.
I wonder who's making the music for Dark Ages.
I don't know.
Oh I thought about playing Quake 2.
Well not Quake...
2 but like...
Quake as well.
Never played MGS4 because no PS3.
I know that's why I went...
So many people.
Like that is the game that...
That...
Needs it the most.
I was really happy when the...
Master Collection came out though.
Because I was like...
Oh my gosh finally more people can at least...
Play the games.
Like when they announced it I was like...
Yes!
It can finally be played more easily.
Um...
So I was really happy about that.
Uh...
But...
2...
Pirate 5...
5...
Unrelated to anything...
But today Nasser restored...
Full connection to Voyager 1.
That thing is 46 years old...
And 24 billion kilometers away from Earth.
I think it's pretty cool.
What?
What the...?
How is the battery lasted for so long?
Magprobe...
That was crazy.
You weren't here but for some reason...
I could hear you get really excited when the MGS stuff was announced.
What like the Delta trailer and stuff?
Yeah...
Space magic.
It uses nuclear decay for power.
Oh wait, actually?
Oh, solar panels make sense, but...
What?
What has it... what has it seen?
Oh my gosh, Google has like an interactive diagram of the Voyager.
That's so cool.
Wow, I can zoom in.
What's the golden record?
Oh.
Carries a phonograph containing sounds and images that would communicate details of life on Earth to extraterrestrials.
What?
That's so cool.
If you ever play Ace Combat 7, would it be okay for me to teach you how to post-stall maneuver?
AKA Top Gun movie.
Yes!
I didn't watch Top Gun.
I didn't watch Top Gun on my last trip.
I was too sleepy.
I eeped the whole time.
I didn't watch a single movie.
Which is extremely rare for me.
Wow, generators powered by plutonium-238 radiation.
Oh, there it is.
How does it... how do they... how do they have the means of communicating with it?
Radio dish antenna for communication with Earth.
But like, how does the radio signals... how do they go so far?
Imaging science.
I wanna know what it's seeing.
What is it seeing right now?
So far away.
They shouted it really loud.
Hella good reception.
But if I go into the mountains, I get... I get no reception.
What's up with this?
Huh?
How are we able to communicate with a satellite that is 24 billion kilometers away from Earth?
But if I go into a grocery store, I lose all connection.
Hey, now.
This is so messed up.
No mountains in space.
You're telling me that not even like the bajillion of meteors that are in space is stopping... you know, are getting in the way?
I doubt that.
For some reason I doubt that.
No ceilings either.
No ceilings in space.
Just vast, vast emptiness.
Space is really empty.
Well, we should all just pack up and move there.
Let's all move to space.
This is me trying to get signal in some of the rooms at Ofgai.
That's true.
I used to think malls installed signal jammers to stop people from having connections.
To instead pay for malls' Wi-Fi.
Did your mall have Wi-Fi you had to pay for?
But no, I kind of believe that.
Because I feel like sometimes grocery stores do stuff like that so that you can't compare prices and go buy it on Amazon.
I feel... I feel like maybe they purposefully build themselves with super concrete or something.
Hopefully I'm able to get them made in time for AX, but...
Minto unit slash morale patches are in the works!
What?!
Maple are on a patch?!
Wait, I wanna see!
Do you have a preview that you can post to Twitter?
Do you have a preview?
Oh.
What do you mean, oh?
Oh, oh.
Oh.
I'm checking my hashtag.
Chat summary.
The viewers are responding to the streamer's remarks about a popular character named Freak Phantom.
The majority of the conversation revolves around jokes related to the streamer's mispronunciation of the character's name.
This is so messed up.
Summary.
This is a Twitch live stream chat where viewers are watching a streamer play the video game Fall Guys.
Viewers are making comments about the streamer's gameplay, the music, and the game itself.
I wasn't playing Fall Guys.
Oh yeah, it was my first game I got 69th.
Yes, ask us about Freak Phantom.
The chat is about a Tetris 99 game where Mint, quote unquote, dominates the other players ruthlessly and quickly, earning many reactions from viewers such as admiration, amusement, and astonishment at the player's skill.
Yippee!
I'm going through the Minto Live tag right now.
The chat is filled with excitement and joy as the streamer affectionately referred to as the Ghost Lady.
Interacts with her viewers and expresses her love for them.
Fans celebrate the streamer's acknowledgement and share their positive reactions, expressing their happiness and gratitude for being loved by her.
Now everybody be great... be... be...
be gratitude.
Express your gratitude as I show my love for you.
Be... be thankful that I am loving you.
Loving you is easy cause you're beautiful.
I'm not gonna say the next part!
Because that's not what we're gonna do.
Thank you, Kami-sama.
Just post it on the tag.
Hi, Mint.
Oh my gosh!
Carnival!
Thank you so much!
Gratitude.
Can't hit the high note?
Not right now.
You're the best Ghost Lady.
I should go take my medicine.
Everybody go take your medicine, okay?
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go rest my throat and rest my brain from the butt wiping that I got done today.
Holy moly.
But I'll see you guys tomorrow and we'll have a grand old time.
Otsumita!
I'm just gonna go.
I'm gonna go take my meds.
Okie dokie.
My head kinda hurts.
Go lay down!
Have a good night.
We'll have fun this weekend, baby.
And yeah.
Get lots of rest.
After the week is over!
Yippee!
Yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee, yippee.
Otsumita!
Bye bye!
Thanks for watching!
Thank you!
Bye bye!